okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others
and I see all kinds of questions stored
up here many about AI so let's talk a
little bit about AI
um let's see prabh says I've been
hearing of AI and llms in the context of
an arms race between countries what do
llms look like scaled up in that manner
I.E like a global llm okay so let's talk
about so chat GPT is uh sort of the
world's most popular example of a large
language model and what is chat GPT well
uh it's something who's whose main
purpose is to write text to fluently
write text in a way that if you give it
a textual prompt it will try and
continue from that prompt in a way that
is typical of the way that text would be
continued based on all the text it's
read from the web and elsewhere
so in other words it's if you say
um the cat sat on thee then the most
likely thing that you'll probably find
on the web for the next word is Matt and
that's what it's probably going to say
is the next word and then it keeps keeps
going from there and it's it's
completely remarkable how coherent kind
of the essays that chat gbt can write
are given that it's really writing them
one word at a time and all it's doing is
saying given everything that came before
what's the the uh either most likely or
or roughly most likely thing to come
next sometimes doesn't pick the
absolutely most likely to come next if
if it always picks they're most likely
to come next it has a terrible habit of
getting stuck in various kinds of Loops
it's kind of like um and what's done is
this there's a notion of a so-called
temperature parameter which says
essentially if the temperature is
non-zero it's like there's a certain
amount of sort of Randomness bubbling
around and it sometimes picks the next
word that isn't the most probable next
word but it's slightly less than the
most problem there's some sort of noise
associated with which word it picks and
it seems like when it's always picking
the the most probable word that it can
get into this very rigid State it's kind
of like zero temperature is as if you
had uh something in physics where you
had a bunch of molecules and at zero
temperature they're all kind of uh
clumped together in a solid it's like a
crystal or something where it just is a
very has a very repetitive structure
whereas if you give it a bit of noise a
bit of temperature so to speak it can
kind of flow around in a in a in a more
random way and you get something which
is a more convincing less rigid kind of
essay it's a very sort of black magic
kind of kind of thing to do in any case
the basic structure of what an llm does
chat EBT and so on do is that you give
it a prompt
it will try and continue from that
prompt based on what it has been trained
from and what it's been trained from is
is roughly the content of the web we'll
talk about that in a moment
I will say that that if you it's a very
significant feature of how llms work
that they're always all they know about
is the past they don't plan for the
future they're going a word at a time
and so one thing that one finds is
things like if you get an llm to
generate an answer
then you say to the llm is that answer
correct
the llm will often be much more
insightful about that answer and
sometimes in the way that chat EBT is
set up it will apologize and say well I
now see that answer isn't correct let me
reformulate that answer why on Earth is
it doing that why didn't it get right
the first time well the answer is
because it couldn't plan so what it's
doing is once it can see that whole
collection of text
that came from the past it can notice
that there are things about it that are
very improbable and weren't really quite
right and it can then go ahead and try
and correct itself but as it was just
going a word at a time filling things in
it couldn't figure that out
so in any case that that's um but the
the basic thing to realize is what
church EBT is doing is it is it has been
made to sort of follow in effect the
statistics of all the texts that it was
trained from what text was it trained
from it was trained from I think around
four billion web pages which are part of
I think it primarily got its training
data from a thing called common crawl
which is a a
um so
okay so the the web is obviously a large
number of interconnected Pages
um many of which are publicly visible uh
but many more of which are in internal
websites of companies or other
organizations and are behind passwords
and things like this
but the number of pages of pure web that
are out there is I don't know 6 billion
is a is a commonly quoted number 10
billion maybe
um it's a little bit hard to make a a
rigid statement of that number because
there can often be things where
different URLs that you can enter will
have for example things after a question
mark in the URL the query string of the
URL could be different and that will
produce a different page but it may not
be a sort of humanly written different
page it may just be something where oh
there's something where you have a
version of the page that's suitable for
people coming from this part of the
world another one for that part of the
world and it was just you know it
changed the currency of some price or
something like this and are those
different pages or are they really the
same intrinsic human written page and
the rest is just a kind of machine
determined modification of the page so
it's a little hard to know uh which
which Pages
um are um
a a kind of um
um you know which are the really
independent pages and then there are
many pages where oh well some people try
and sort of
um become less popular in these days to
sort of trick search engines by having
giant collections of pages that are
machine generated that are intended to
sort of uh catch the The Thing by just
being a web page that has this exact
phrase on it and when people search for
that phrase they'll end up on that
website so you know the number of human
written pages are not completely clear
but the number that are I think in in
the oh yeah so how does how does one
sample the web well what one can do to
sample the web is you might say well
let's just start from one website and
then just keep following links you
follow links you follow more links you
follow more links you try and arrange it
so that if you ever get to a web page
you've been at before you know you've
been there before and you don't have to
re-refollow those links so to speak
um but so what typically happens in
crawling the web is you'll have to start
from some seed web pages that say well
this links and eventually starting from
that web page you'll sort of visit the
whole web now there may be parts of the
web that are completely disconnected
from from everything else where nothing
links to that page that page May link
out to other pages but nothing links
into that page so that's a a an issue in
sort of defining how you how you visit
the web and whether there are parts the
web that are sort of separate Islands
not found by sort of a a a basic crawl
so common crawl is is is a thing that's
been being done how long is it 15 years
maybe
um that is sort of an open crawl over
the web
pulling the web it's kind of complicated
what you get back when you crawl the web
because a web page particularly in
modern times is full of lots of singing
dancing stuff in many cases it's not
just text it's text that can be
determined by you know JavaScript code
that's running in your browser that you
know makes something open and close and
do this and that and the other
um and so there are a lot of questions
about what you actually get back when
you call the web and there are these
different kinds of files uh warp files a
one one type of file that represent the
actual uh sort of bag of bits that are
sent back to your web browser by
um uh web archive file as with what that
stands for it's sort of the bag that
that's a collection of uh sort of the
bag of bits that's sent back to your
browser when you go to a web page and
then that bag of bits will be rendered
in some way on your particular browser
and again it gets more tricky because
it's a question of what uh what does the
JavaScript that's in that page do to
pull in more things from the page and so
on so it's a slightly tricky thing but
if you're just a regular simple Ai and
llm whatever mostly what you're going to
be interested in is what's the what's
the text on that page and so the
extraction of that plain text is not
completely straightforward in many cases
um and it's not obvious that you can get
the whole plain text maybe you have to
actually you know explicitly run the web
page in a browser to be able to see what
text is on there and then maybe it will
just render but it's actually inside
just an image it's not really text like
characters and so on it can get kind of
tricky but in any case the the end
result of that is there's uh about 4
billion I think
um pages that are sort of public Pages
which anybody can visit on the web that
are
um that are accessible and in this
common call for example and so that's a
thing that sort of any llm can get
access to
then there's other things that an llm
can train on for example books
and they're about believed to be maybe
130 million books that have ever been
published
and uh maybe 10 million of them have
been scanned and maybe a few million of
those are sort of accessible for llms to
read and that's another uh by scand I
mean that the you know that the the
optical character recognition has been
done so that one can pick out I mean one
thing is just to get the images of the
pages of the book another is to actually
pick out the letters and the words and
all that kind of thing but so there's a
few million books so the end result is
there's maybe a trillion words
um that are out there uh somewhat
publicly accessible that llms can train
on and most of the llms have been
trained on all of that stuff kind of
like the the collection of knowledge
this is what our civilization has
produced it's trillion words and um uh
let's uh you know that's what's
accessible okay
so now the question was asking what does
it look like when llms are scaled up
well
there are two kinds of ways to scale up
an llm one is to give it more training
data and the other is to have it have a
be a bigger neural network so in terms
of the more training data
um there's this big collection of
training data that sort of everybody has
access to when you go beyond that
it's complicated so for example
uh the internet archive the
um has about 500 billion pages I believe
um that it has collected over the last
26 years maybe that it's been in
operation
and uh they don't know how many of those
pages that you need they haven't been
able to know that that's a complicated
computational calculation so to speak
it's something where it's not even clear
what it means by unique as I mentioned
before there could be you know what size
of change makes it really A Different
Page Etc et cetera et cetera so there's
there's a large factor maybe a factor of
a hundred more pages in sort of the
history of the web but it's not clear
how unique those pages are
um that's that's one thing another thing
is that there are lots of internal
websites behind passwords
Etc et cetera et cetera believed to be
at least a hundred times what's in the
public web
so you know right there we've got uh you
know a lot more training data that's
potentially available
um in the end there's you know how much
data is there that's just sitting on
people's local computers and so on as as
information that could be used to train
an llm textual stuff I don't know how
much more there really is
um than what I just mentioned I think
there's a lot of sort of structured
numerical type data in databases
um there's a lot of kind of that that's
one category of thing
um then
uh so I I tend to think that the um uh
yeah so that that that's that part I
mean there's there's other kinds of data
like videos for example and there's just
a vast amount of video data that comes
from things like security cameras and so
on I mean there's video data that is
sort of the the actual feature films
that get made there's video data that is
sort of all of us random people
uploading things to YouTube like this
live stream for example
um and then there's uh kind of typically
uh then there's just absolutely gobs of
kind of just video that has been running
uh you know a security camera that's
just recording video and sending it to
the cloud somewhere and just that stuff
getting stored and that kind of thing
doesn't have textual data in it many of
the sort of let's say random Youtube
videos do have textual data and there is
some amount of uh of transcripting
that's been done that allows one to have
sort of text from those videos uh more
importantly in the future it will be
possible to train from the videos
directly and uh not to get text but to
get sort of training about what happens
the world you know training about sort
of what what are the the things that
give us humans physical intuition about
you know you you drop something and it
falls and that's sort of things that
that's the type of training you can get
from videos and that's uh that's a sort
of a Coming Attraction and one's
starting to see some video generation
technology for for AIS of of make a
plausible video or the analog the direct
analog of what to what uh chat gbt does
of can you continue this text from a
prompt would be here's the beginning of
a video how would this video continue
um and uh it's an interesting issue the
sort of video prompting world of you
know can you uh do something which is
kind of a a um a simple video prompt and
then have the thing continue from that
and I think uh just as
there is a certain level of ability to
go from sort of a sketch to a full kind
of uh elaborately AI generated uh
picture
um the same may be true for videos where
you can go from a little charade type
thing that you do to then uh having it
sort of fill that in to be a full
convincing kind of kind of video I I
have to say the demos I've seen of that
so far have not been particularly
particularly sophisticated but I'm sure
that will that will improve
so the back back to sort of all the data
that's potentially available I should
say that to give a sense of scale uh
let's see I personally have written 50
million words in my life
so uh and compared to a trillion words
that are out there in the Public Public
sort of web and so on
um that's you know I've been reasonably
prolific at writing things lots of
emails lots of other kinds of documents
I think I published
oh what is it 15 million words I think
um I'm forgetting these numbers now
um but um
um and and in fact in these live streams
that I've been doing
um that contributes uh you know
10 ish million or more words
um I I wrote down all these things I've
already forgotten them
um but uh it's of that order uh just
from the transcripts of these kinds of
live streams
so give some sense of scale
um now you know one thing people have
raised is maybe there are countries that
have particular sort of caches of
material uh for example in their
National libraries things like this and
yeah it's a small effect I don't think
it's a huge effect I think that the vast
majority of what is available to train
an llm is sort of already out there now
I should say another thing
um what are you training in llm about
well another element is mostly about
generating text
and it also has the ability if it has
seen
mentioned you know the population of the
United States is 330 million that's a
piece of text it might have seen another
piece of text that said the population
in the United States is 120 million
because that was a book published
whenever it was
um it doesn't have an any sort of
intrinsic sense of being able to compute
with that number it's just what was
textually uh what textually appeared but
the fact is that the the main skill in a
sense of an llm is its ability to fluid
fluently generate language and fluently
understand language
um the knowing all those facts all those
specific the population is 330 million
or whatever it is now
um is is really a separate thing that's
the kind of thing that we've built in
both language with Alpha we've been the
main sort of uh thing that's that's
actually trying to do a good job of
getting sort of correct computable data
um to feed these kinds of things
and I think what's going to happen is
that they're going to be much more
stripped down llms which are just the
language part and whenever they need a
fact they'll call out to for example
wolf and plug-in for track gbt for
example to get that fact they won't have
to store within the llm itself all of
those facts they'll just kind of know
the linguistic flow of what it means to
you know what populations are and what
things usually say about that are now
the other thing that llms have is they
have a certain amount of human-like
common sense
so even though they don't know the
precise weight of an elephant perhaps
they do have some sense from common
sense that an elephant weighs more than
a dog let's say even though they don't
necessarily know the actual weights of
those things and different breeds of
dogs and all those kinds of details but
that's sort of a common sense fact and
just as we humans would have that Common
Sense fact even though we couldn't tell
you most of us couldn't tell you you
know an elephant weighs X number of tons
and things like this
um so there's sort of a two things that
need to be captured in the kind of uh uh
the the sort of minimal llm the fluent
language part and Common Sense facts
about the world or common sense about
the world there isn't really fact it's
common sense about the world the
detailed facts can be factored out and
that's where our technology for example
comes in at technology also lets you not
only have the detailed facts but also
have um uh the the computation from sort
of uh uh sort of a computational
foundation from Facts from algorithms
and so on to compute things that have
never been put on the web that have
never been written down as text which
are incense new knowledge that's being
created
um by by computation uh new you know
work out this math problem work out this
chemistry thing it's never been computed
before
um but that's something new that you can
generate that's not at all what llms set
up to do llms are set up to you know
continue the text from a prompt and um
uh and be able to fluently produce text
so
I think the you know the future llm will
be this quite stripped down thing that
mostly is about structure of language
and Common Sense calling out to kind of
a computational knowledge engine which
we have the main one that exists in in
the in the world
um and uh uh and and using that to kind
of um Supply the the kind of the factual
data now it's a good thing partly
because if an llm is left to make up the
factual data it's going to make up
something that statistically plausible
but maybe complete nonsense and that's
what we see happening with sort of raw
chat gbt for example a lot of the time
now I mean it also has to be said that
that oh an llm can write text that's
fiction as well as fact and you don't
want to lock it down and say you can
only write things that you can validate
a true in the world because you also
want it to be able to write uh pieces of
fiction and so on that's that's a useful
thing for it to be able to do even at
the level of sort of micro fiction as
you might call it where you know let's
say you're trying to make up fun word
problems uh in in math education for
instance you might say make up something
that is a word problem that's about you
know a city populated by flying
jellyfish or something and you know no
such thing actually exists in the world
but you can make up a a nice little
story that has counts the tentacles of
the jellyfish or whatever it wants to do
in the math word problem
um and uh gives it a framing that
fictional Framing and that's a a very
valid thing to want to do and a very
useful thing in terms of sort of humor
and entertainment and communication and
so on um that has nothing to do with
kind of check the facts type thing
so
okay so that that's on the on the
subject of sort of the data that goes
into an llm where do you get it from are
there kind of uh specific countries for
example that could mine a lot more data
um as I say I think the main source is
probably things like National libraries
um uh that there's um uh you know in
terms of the um yeah that that's so then
the next question is okay you're going
to train the llm as I say I think in the
future the pure llm component will
actually be quite small and a lot of it
will just be sort of fact back up
um and but let's imagine that you say
well I want to train a bigger you know
using current technology without having
done the sort of fact factoring so to
speak I want to just train a bigger llm
so one question is you know what what
kind of computation resources do you
need to do that how much does it cost uh
mostly mostly ones using Graphics
processing units gpus
to uh to do that training because a lot
of neural net training can be done with
a high degree of of local parallelism
where a lot of operations can be done
kind of uh in parallel and that's what
gpus are set up to have sort of do
operations across big arrays of numbers
where each of the elements in the array
are being computed in parallel at the
same time as the other elements more
efficient than a typical CPU and a
typical computer
so you know one wants lots of gpus and
one wants to run them for a long time
there's this kind of notion of a
foundation model which is sort of the
the basic llm that's created from its
from its big training set and so on the
thing that's been a big surprise to
everybody is that given that Foundation
model it's often possible usually
possible it seems to get that model to
sort of do particular things you want by
doing just prompting
so
um
uh there's this notion of kind of zero
shot learning where you just basically
you pretty much just ask the llm to do
what you want and it just based on its
existing training it does it there's
sort of few shot learning where you give
the llm a bunch of examples of what you
want and you kind of you kind of get it
in the groove so to speak and then you
ask it the thing you really want to ask
it
and quite why that works is not
completely clear in other words the what
probably is the case is that by giving
it those examples you're kind of uh
you're you're priming it to kind of use
that part of its kind of memory in some
sense that is somehow aligned with those
examples and so it kind of follows along
from those examples to do things the way
you want it done
um it's kind of as if there's this sort
of big space of kind of uh not quite
knowledge but uh sense or something
Common Sense language and common sense
of the llm and you're you're saying I
want to walk around in this particular
area and you're identifying that by
giving this these kind of examples and
these these prompts and so on but but
just how that works is not very well
understood and it's not known whether
you can sort of get further by training
a new and different Foundation model my
guess is probably you cannot probably
there's sort of a limit that's sort of
the Corpus of human knowledge it defines
language as we kind of typically use it
and once you've got that you're kind of
done and most of the rest of what you
will add is more structured
computational knowledge more algorithmic
knowledge which really isn't the domain
of our labs
um but we'll see how that works and and
sort of a question of of okay the
foundation model how do you train it you
know open AI has one anthropic has one
there's one called Bloom there's one um
oh gosh they're llama
there's an alpaca there's a there's a
whole zoo oh it really does sound like a
zoo doesn't it with llamas and alpacas
and things like that running around of
of foundation models that people are
mostly large companies have been
training
and it's a subject of some debate how
much it really does cost and should cost
to train a foundation model it's also a
question of once you have one such
Foundation model can you train another
one from it and how does that work can
you for example one of the things that's
been found is that you get one of these
big foundation models that's you know uh
terabytes of data and then you can
distill that model you can actually sort
of make a trainer model from that model
and it is a simpler model and the
simpler model still works but you can't
go so far as people know yet directly to
the simpler model you have to go to this
big model and then distill the big model
down you don't get to go right now yet
to the to the small model directly
um and you know estimates range in the
you know oh it costs a billion dollars
to train a foundation model to it costs
half a million dollars to train a
foundation model so you can take your
pick right now of uh of what the what
the correct number is I think it depends
on a lot on where you're starting from
and how much of the existing material
existing training and so on you're
making use of my guess is that in time
the the cost to do any training that any
reasonable person would try to do given
the resources that already exist will
push things down to a much lower cost
for even training a foundation model but
it's not even clear it's it's useful to
train that uh you know another
Foundation model one might just use one
of the ones that's been trained from a
very similar training set with a very
similar internal architecture for the
for the neural net and so on just use it
and and build things on top of it and
use few shot learning prompting
Etc et cetera Etc to uh to get the model
to do what one wants
so I think um
uh I'm I'm kind of not expecting that
there will be a a kind of uh somebody
has the greatest llm
um because they had fundamentally more
training data fundamentally more larger
model things like this uh now it's not
to say that that right now uh you know
there's a lot of a lot of good
engineering work that's been done in
building the successful llm models and
that creates a um there's a there's all
kinds of details and tricks and uh and
just good software engineering and and
good kind of prompting uh good
fine-tuning and so on of the model to
make it say sensible things not say
totally crazy things not go completely
Bonkers
um not uh uh and you know generally
follow instructions and so on that's a
there's a whole lot of kind of uh sort
of typical engineering technology that's
gone into that that's not so much in the
big picture of how the llms work
um
let's see
uh
live shot is asking here about what
about model interoperability uh where
are we on research for that do we need
to develop new and more sophisticated
mathematics to begin to understand these
black box models do you think in time
we'll be able to do causal inference
with them
well okay so the question of of why
doesn't llm work how does it really work
I wrote this little book look at this I
even have a copy here there we go actual
little book
um the uh there's a very little book
it's it's um it's my my smallest ever
book I think I have look I have another
one here this is uh this is my biggest I
think no this is my second biggest ever
book new kind of science that I wrote 20
years ago the the uh uh the Mathematica
book
um actually was was even bigger than
this before we just switched to uh
making it be be online and now it will
be like 300 000 Pages if we were to
print it out
um but uh in any case this whole
question about sort of um
um
how does something like chat GPT how do
llms work inside
uh there's two levels of answer to that
question there's how do the neural Nets
that people have put together to build
the llm how do they work and the second
is is there a science of how llms work
is there a kind of larger scale picture
where we can start to say oh yes I
understand how that works in the same
sense that you know if you were looking
at I don't know the um uh I don't know
the the
blow of air in the atmosphere or
something you could at one level say
well I know how all the molecules are
moving around in the air
um but at another level you could say
I'm describing the motion of the air in
terms of cyclones and high pressure
regions and fluid dynamics and and all
those sorts of things so I think the
question we we know kind of at the
engineering sort of uh neural net
structure level we kind of know how llms
get built
um it's actually surprisingly
straightforward in a sense it's
surprisingly much you just put together
these things there are a few very
important tricks about how it works but
you just sort of put these things
together and and then
uh and then you train them by giving
them lots of examples of text and so on
and that's kind of the how they work at
the level of sort of the rules which
Define their operation the second thing
is what's the big picture description of
what they're doing
and I think that
the thing that we're really learning
from llms is that language has kind of a
um an emergent structure
that we've never really cataloged very
well before I mean we've cataloged sort
of standard syntactic grammar we know
that sort of a sentence is composed of
things like a noun phrase a verb phrase
a noun phrase the noun phrase might
contain an adjective and a noun
etc etc etc we know this kind of it's a
hierarchical structure of syntactic
grammar that it says it's sort of the
construction kit for putting
um
uh for for putting sentences together
but that construction kit allows you to
put together sentences which
um don't
uh don't mean anything to us I mean we
could put together you know happy
electrons
um dance
in purple
you know it's syntactically in terms of
syntactic grammar that's a correct
sentence happy adjective electrons noun
noun phrase
dance verb you know Etc et cetera et
cetera it's it's syntactically correct
but
um the you know what does that mean do
we have a way of taking that sentence
and converting it in our minds to
something that we can reason from and so
on well not really it just seems like a
nonsense sentence
uh you know could it be have a whole
setup and a poem or something where
you've defined something where that
sentence is really going to have a
significance to us yes it could but on
its own without further context that
sentence is kind of doesn't doesn't fire
some kind of meaning off in our brains
I think it's worth understanding that
when we talk about understanding
language
um it's a bit of a floppy thing when it
comes to just saying well I understood
that or I didn't understand that what
does it mean to understand that
in the case of of wolf malpha and our
sort of modern technology stack uh
there's a very clear notion of we
understand it which is we converted from
the natural language into our precise
computational language and in that
precise computational language we can
compute whatever we want from that sort
of computationalified statement so you
know in the computational language we
have a notion of electrons we might say
an electron with an energy of whatever
and we could then compute for an
electron of energy whatever how far will
it go in a block of aluminum you know
what is its relativistic correction to
its its uh oh I don't know its mass or
whatever we can compute all those things
about the electron because we understood
in some sort of computational sense of
understanding what an electron of energy
you know two million electron volts or
whatever it is
um means
um now that that's it's less clear how
that works when it comes to sort of a
human understanding language uh probably
the best thing we could say is can one
take the thing you were told in language
and reason from it deduce other things
from it or is it kind of a I'm stuck
because I have no idea what a happy
electron dancing might be about
um but okay the question is if we go
beyond the syntactic grammar and we say
what about sentences that really do have
a meaning to us that really do sort of
fire off that I understand it I mean it
I I know what it means I can I can
deduce things from it what about those
kinds of sentences is there a kind of
semantic grammar a meaning-based grammar
that defines what are valid sentences of
that kind I think what the success of
chat GPT is showing us is that yes there
really are additional rules about sort
of how to make sentences that can be
meaningful and there are sentences that
can be perfectly meaningful I think I I
gave in the book that I wrote about you
know the sentence the elephant flew to
the moon
which is a perfectly meaningful that
that conjures up a meaning to us in our
in our minds it doesn't happen to be a
factual sentence you know so far as we
know no elephant has ever flown to the
Moon
um but we can have some concept of what
it would mean for that to be a thing and
so I think that there's a level of kind
of we go from the purely syntactic to
the nouns and verbs match up
to the sort of the semantic of there's
the thing have a a kind of a a a way in
which we can unpack it and say we can
deduce things from that sentence and
then sometimes people talk about
pragmatics as sort of another level of
meaning which is sort of does it
actually happen in the world
um and so there are these different
levels but the thing that we really
clearly I think uh has been exposed to
us is that there is this semantic level
that we haven't really cataloged very
well there are examples where we have
cataloged it uh most famous example is
logic where uh one can have a sentence
that says
um something like uh
um
if the sun is shining then it cannot be
raining
um and that implies
um
let's see I'm now getting stuck on this
logic if it implies if the sun is
shining then it is not raining means
um
if if it is raining then the sun is not
shining yeah I think I got that right
um but that logical structure
uh P implies not Q then
not Q implies
am I getting this the wrong way around I
think I've I've messed it up how
embarrassing but any case you get the
basic idea that that the the question of
what implies what with the knots and so
on in it
um is something that is more General
than talking about raining in sunny and
sunny and so on it's something that
there is a a a a general semantic
structure that you can lift out of the
specifics of sentences about sun and
rain and you know mammals and
warm-blooded and all these other kinds
of things you might discuss
um and I think that
is uh that's an example of where you can
get sort of a semantic grammar of how
things work
now in the case of logic that was
discovered two thousand
400 years ago or something by by
Aristotle
um who sort of went through and and
looked at lots of examples of sentences
presumably in Greek
um and saw kind of what the patterns of
those sentences were and then said we
can lift this formal thing out of that
well there are many other formal things
that we can list out of sentences just
haven't been done people just haven't
looked at those things particularly
um and um uh in in some sense the uh one
could think of mathematics you know
things like arithmetic as being another
kind of lifting of something formal out
of what was originally described mostly
in words
um but there's much more of that that I
think can be done and maybe I've been
thinking about doing this actually for
years
um now the llms are waving this giant
flag that says this really can be done
so so that's kind of the um the way that
I think we're going to sort of make
something which is more like a semantic
grammar construction kit and that's
going to be another piece that's going
to be a way that we can get sort of a
higher level understanding of what's
Happening inside another land now the
other piece of llms is the sort of
Common Sense piece and I don't know to
what extent that will be captured by
something that's like the semantic
grammar thing I mean in a sense that's
going a little bit beyond you know
what's the relationship between the
semantic grammar and the common sense
kind of thing in other words uh you know
if um
uh to what extent does the semantics
capture the fact that elephants can't
fly unless they're put on a plane or
whatever
um and uh uh and to what extent is that
something that goes beyond that and is
really talking about sort of the way the
world happens to be rather than the
things you need to put together in that
way in order to have something quotes
meaningful
um but I think that's um uh you know
that's that's the thing now in terms of
sort of if one can abstract from a model
something that's about sort of semantic
grammar then that in principle is
something that doesn't depend on that's
something that one can kind of Transport
that layer of description you know just
as one can transport a a typical program
uh you know in a language computational
language or programming language you can
transport it from one computer to
another and it can be separately
interpreted on those different computers
um so one can more expect to do that
um if one has some sort of higher level
semantic description one one is just
dealing with the raw sort of firing of
neurons and a neural Nets that's
completely non-transportable unless you
have an identical neural net you won't
be able to have uh that you won't be
able to kind of make use of the
particular pattern of weights from when
you're on that to another one and so on
uh
okay there's a question from
anti-crime do you agree with statements
by Jana Kun and Andrew ing that AGI
still decades away and can't be achieved
with the current Transformer
architecture result is the parameter and
token count so to unpack that question a
bit AGI is this notion of artificial
general intelligence
I think this notion is kind of a weird
notion
it's kind of like it comes from a little
bit the history of talking about human
intelligence and it comes from I think
the 1930s when uh there was this kind of
question of uh okay what does it mean to
be intelligent as a human you know
they're in humans are more intelligent
humans are less intelligent
I don't know quite what this means and
there was this idea
uh produced of this notion of the G the
quotient of general intelligence
and the idea was what we can give these
tests we can give you know this thing
where okay you have these like these
Progressive Matrix tests where you say
there are you know these things uh you
know there's this pattern of of squares
and triangles or something and then
there's another pattern and then there's
this one what's the odd one out out of
these collection of things with squares
and triangles and so on
um these are an attempt to sort of
abstract from the particulars of the
world and talking about I don't know
physics or mathematics or whatever else
to abstract something which is the
essence of what constitutes kind of uh
thinking and deduction
abstracted from all of the kind of uh
knowledge of the world I think this is a
troubled concept to begin with I mean I
think that the the only real sort of
thing like that that we might be able to
do is to say make let's look at
computation let's let's imagine that the
thing that's abstracted from all the
detailed particulars of our world is
this General notion of computation
that's something we we learn very
clearly from our physics project and
from the idea of the rouliad and so on
that then this is going off in a in a
quite different direction but that
really thing everything in the universe
we can think of as being ultimately
computational so in a sense if you want
to abstract from the particulars you end
up with sort of raw computation so you
might say well you know to test out sort
of how intelligent that brain is let's
have it just deal with raw computation
independent of the particulars of having
ever seen you know sequences of numbers
and fractions and all this kind of thing
but then so then what you're imagining
is well let's see whether for example a
brain can run a program in its you know
in its mind
um the fact is I don't think most people
would think of typical everyday Notions
of intelligence as being much related to
the ability to run a program in one's
head I think very few people can run
programs in their heads I'm not even
sure I've ever even tried
um the uh you know if if you asked me
what does this piece of Orphan language
code do run it in your head to figure
out well maybe I could do a little bit
of that but I wouldn't be particularly
proud about being able to do that really
well that wouldn't be something that
would make me feel like I've got
something that is really great and you
know a sign of what one might think of
as good of sort of high intelligence or
something like this so I think it's this
this notion of how do you have something
that is sort of an abstract back to
General intelligence and I you know
there's there's plenty of of realization
that if you you know you can Define sort
of what what is intelligence good for
well it lets you figure out more stuff
more quickly or does it let you figure
out stuff more deeply or does it let you
make connections between this and that
does it prevent you from doing things
that one might think were kind of stupid
does it does it make you more able to uh
sort of deal with a new situation does
it you know there are all these
different criteria and each one is hard
to measure and would it's hard to
measure
in a uh you know the well the the ones
that are fairly easy to measure but
they're ones that don't seem to relate
much to what one might in an everyday
sense mean oh this person's being really
smart in this way
um you know I think my my friend Howard
Gardner is famous for having talked
about this theory of multiple
intelligences of different kinds of I'm
not sure I can repeat what they are but
but um in addition to this sort of
analytical reasoning type of thing
there's sort of things about emotional
intelligence and other kinds of things
which are in a sense I suppose one could
talk about them as abilities of people I
mean you know different people have
different kinds of abilities which you
know some people might be really good at
you know hand-eye coordination or
something like that or really good at
running fast or whatever else and other
people might be really good at um uh
being able to do mental arithmetic and
other people might be really good at
figuring out deep connections between
different areas of mathematics and other
people might be really fast at solving
kind of puzzle math problems those kinds
of things there's there's lots of
different attributes that we all have
um just as there are uh you know we have
different attributes and in many many
ways and this notion of there's a linear
scale of intelligence somewhere
gradually you know the machines are
catching up sort of on the linear scale
of intelligence I think it's sort of a
flawed concept
um now I think that um in uh you know
you can ask when you look at things we
humans can do you can say can the
machines do that too
and one of the big things that looked
like it was a very human-like activity
that wasn't really accessible to
machines was writing a fluent essay well
you know last few months it's become
clear that yes in fact leveraging
building on top of the trillion words
that we humans have written yes machines
can learn to do that too and and what
would it mean to write an essay in the
abstract without making use of those
trillion words you know anybody can
write an essay in the abstract it just
goes
something like that some abstract thing
without a connection to human language
and things we humans talk about and so
on it's it's an essay which has no human
meaning it's something where we could
get a we could get something
computationally generated but we can say
look at how marvelously that rule has
been followed to generate this very
elaborate sequence of ones and zeros and
so on it doesn't that has no sort of
resonance no relevance
to us as humans so it's inevitable that
a sort of human recognizable fluent
essay is going to leverage the actual
things that we humans use as language
and have and have written about
so then if you ask the question well you
know are there things that the machines
can't do that we can do
you know we can start enumerating
different kinds of possible things
people talk about oh I don't know can
the machine have emotions I think that's
actually a rather straightforward one I
think that's one where people haven't
really uh you know I wouldn't be
surprised if another generation of LMS
wouldn't end up being sort of you can
certainly prompt an llm to say you know
write a happy story write a sad story
these kinds of things and I don't know
quite what it means for it to have
emotions I mean if you say oh you you
get it really annoyed at this point by
by you know telling it by keeping on
telling it oh you've got that wrong you
got that wrong if if the llm has Pride
which I'm not quite sure that it does
um when I say you know if it has Pride
things like this the fact is it's
learning from what we humans have put
out there on the web so insofar as the
texts that we humans have written shows
signs of Pride the llm is going to show
signs of Pride as well because it is it
is feeding back to us the kind of
consensus of what we humans have put out
there in the world it's you know if if
we are in in some aggregate sense
prideful so will it be
um but you can certainly prompt it to
take on various different personas
um and that have different emotional
states and so on so I kind of think that
um the sort of you know can the machine
quotes have emotions it's uh
um
uh it's kind of a um uh a thing that um
has uh you know it doesn't it doesn't um
it doesn't have a um uh
uh
doesn't really have a an intrinsic
meaning you know I'm reminded of
something
um the uh
um uh
um I I'm a I'm a collector of of endless
data about everything including about
myself and so I I recently and one thing
I'd never done was to get a whole body
MRI scan just you know see inside and
just whatever it's very I'm I'm rather
squeamish so that's that's a strange
thing to do but but I was I was just
pulled up a bunch of the images of this
and you know you see that the whole
everything inside and yes there's a
brain inside the you know inside the
skull and so on and and you look at it
and I have to say it really when people
are having this whole discussion about
you know do computers have Consciousness
and this that and the other and you're
looking at this MRI of sort of your own
brain let's say it just looks
tremendously kind of structural and
mechanical so to speak it's kind of like
from inside that is the internal
experience that we have of uh of being
here so to speak and it just it it makes
one to me at least it makes one feel
well you know it's just a bunch of you
know neurons just a bunch of you know
molecular biology just a bunch of just
like a computer is just a bunch of
semiconductor technology and so on and
it it uh I suppose I I I still have to
come more to terms with this because
it's some and maybe um
this the sort of the the the fact that
one has this internal experience
yet one can look at kind of the external
manifestation of you know where this
experience is coming from just makes one
feel that it is sort of a it just it
really is that there is just internal
experience is just a sort of a meta
phenomenon
um that comes out of the sort of pure
physicality I mean it's it's not that
there's some even though it feels like
there's something very special and
different and some spark of
Consciousness and so on it just somehow
drives home the fact that it's all very
material at some level and one can you
know one could imagine sort of getting
inside the AI and and having and having
sort of one begins to be able to perhaps
imagine sort of getting inside the AI
and and and having its internal
experience so to speak as well
um but uh
um
so
uh let's see the the the
um
the question of of um so what else is
there that sort of uh we can do that the
AIS can't do
um and that would define a notion of
sort of reaching this point of of
artificial general intelligence and so
on you know if you start asking over
over you know all these different pieces
of functionality that we have things we
can do we can walk around we can
manipulate things in the world without
with our hands things like this we can
uh do do all sorts of things like that
well clearly an llam that's sitting
inside a computer that doesn't have any
hands isn't going to be able to pick up
and grab something you know to to grab
something so you have to sort of uh to
to get to those kinds of human
capabilities you have to kind of embody
the AI in some ways so that it can it
can interact directly with the physical
world
and you know as one starts thinking
about those kinds of things and then you
say well but but look it can't you know
you could complain the AI can't
experience eating and food and taste and
so on well you can't do that unless you
give it a mouth more or less and in the
end you say well yeah I can't experience
this and this and this you know it
um uh well in the end the only thing
that can experience exactly what we
humans experience is US humans with our
biology and our particular construction
and so on and in addition the you know
another feature the kind of web of
history that we are embedded in you know
we are at this point in the evolution of
of civilization and society and we have
these connections to all these different
people and so on and those are things
which are you know we're embedded in
this web and the AI is not part of that
now you know sort of an interesting
thing that as AIS get more integrated
into the fabric of society I mean I
think you know we can readily expect
that on your average kind of I don't
know you know chat group somewhere
there'll come a time when it's when it's
routine for some of the members of the
group to be to be Bots
um I mean that's already true in some
exotic cases but I think it will be and
sometimes in games and things but I
think it will be quite routinely true
and these Bots will sometimes have a lot
of memory they'll be they'll tell great
jokes they'll be able to say oh yeah you
talked about that two years ago and you
know blah blah blah blah and they'll
they'll be good company and so I think
that may change people's perception of
sort of uh how much how integrated into
sort of our web of History AIS can be
right now they're not right now they're
they're from the outside so to speak but
I think that will be in decreasingly
true
and you know when we start asking okay
well when we have a bot in our little
chat group and the bot is one of the
favorite members of the chat group well
then you know what's
you know what's not human well you say
the bot can't you know uh get up and
take a walk well yeah unless it happened
to be you know a computer that's
embedded in a robot that has legs and
can get up and take a walk but that's
not the the form of interaction that
we're having with it in that in our chat
group and so that that's probably not so
relevant to that we also can say you
know oh but the the uh the bot doesn't
experience the notion of mortality for
example
um yeah I mean you know unless unless
the bot's going to meet its end in some
uh you know uh traumatic way where some
microprocessor inside it suddenly blows
up or something like that
um you know it has a microprocessor
attack or some such other thing
um and uh you know maybe then it it gets
into the same kind of uh same kind of
notion as we humans are in right now but
I think um uh so I'm I'm kind of
uh and then if you ask the question what
does it seem like so let's say that the
bot in the chat group is just really the
smartest thing in the room so to speak
and it's what does that mean well there
are some definite things that could mean
I mean for example it could have a
better memory than everybody else in the
room
easy
it could be you know it could respond a
bit faster it could see the consequences
of things that are being discussed it
could it could kind of get to the end of
the argument much quicker than um uh
than the other the other things people
whatever in the room
um it could uh uh but it's an
interesting question what would it be
like
to have uh uh you know in in um uh you
know it can it can deduce things it can
get you know that that's one sort of I
mean look I I mean one notice is just in
terms of uh you know practically dealing
with people and so on in the world one
notices uh situations in which you know
somebody will figure things out it's
like uh you kind of something comes up
in some conversation and you can see
somebody is just like the wheels are
turning and like boom they get there
they get to the answer they get to the
next right thing to say and um uh you
know that can happen faster it can
happen slower or sometimes it's like
you've got some question about how
things should work in the world and
people are just like sitting around and
nobody can figure it out and then
somebody says I can figure it out and
you feel like that's uh you know that
was somebody being smart
and so the question would be if you have
AIS kind of sitting around in the world
and trying to figure things out it's
kind of like how do we solve uh some uh
you know first thing to do is we have to
say well what do we want them to solve
do we solve you know can AIS you know uh
solve the problem of
I don't know uh
what's a what's a good problem I don't
know solve the problem of climate change
you know let's say to pick a a
horrifyingly complicated one
well the AI must say I got a great idea
you know just uh you know put iron into
the oceans and you'll get lots more
algae and they'll absorb uh you know
carbon dioxide or put um uh put some
different uh you know whatever it is uh
calcium carbonate or something into the
into the oceans that'll absorb things
put aerosols in the atmosphere and so on
then people will say well but wait a
minute that's not quite what we want to
do because this or that or they'll say
well actually you know forget all of
that technology the human race has just
go back to uh kind of Paleolithic times
and you'll solve you know you'll you'll
at least reverse out the human part of
of sort of uh uh of climate change and
then people say but I don't want to do
that and you know but then you've got
something where it's not really up to
the you know the AI can quote solve the
problem but there's a what do the humans
want how does that connect to sort of
the web of human
uh of human kinds of things and it's not
really a question I think of
um I I mean I I suppose I suppose in
that case one could imagine something
where it's like okay here's a
geoengineering solution for climate
change where you can which nobody
thought of and which is uh absolutely
you know it just like offsets whatever
it is you know the the CO2 that's
generated by all the factories in the
world and it does so in a way that
perfectly
negates it and does nothing else
um maybe there's a way to figure that
out and maybe we'd be deeply impressed
if some AI was just hanging out and said
okay humans this is the thing to do
my guess is that in most of those cases
there are many sort of tentacles to the
answer that depend a lot on human
preferences and things where it's not
really quite a question of just being
you know the smartest AI in the room and
I'm trying to think about things as I'm
because I'm saying this I'm I'm
wondering uh you know things I've seen
where it's kind of like one figures out
a solution to a problem
um that uh well okay so here's here's an
interesting question if we'd had a super
smart AI
and we go back five years
would it have said
would it have been able to figure out
that gosh in five years we're going to
have llms that can produce you know
fluent linguistic output and so on
would it have been able to figure that
out well there's a big catch to this
whole thing which is this phenomenon
that I call computational irreducibility
this idea that even if you kind of know
the rules by which things operate you
may not be able to work out what will
happen much more efficiently than just
running those rules and seeing what
happens and so I suspect in a case like
that well it's a good question would
would the AI be able to figure out more
about sort of the science of llms the
human narrative science of llms to be
able to give us a sort of a new science
that would show us oh there's going to
be another lemon five years when you get
this number of uh of of uh network
connections and so on that we'll be able
to do this or that thing
um but I'm I'm you know it's not
to me
as some uh then then the question of I
mean I think the original question here
was will the current architecture of
llms get one to sort of everything
that's computationally possible the
answer is definitely not
um that's that's pretty easy to see just
because the nature of that architecture
is a very kind of um it's a you know
every word that's generated you just run
a fixed set of operations and it's a lot
of operations it's billions of
operations but it's still a fixed set of
operations you go on to the next thing
there's no it's not uh you can in
principle do arbitrary computations that
way but only in a very ornate fashion
and I don't think that's the realistic
way that one's going to sort of be able
to tap into sort of the full power of
computation so yes I think that to get
to the full power of computation you
need something beyond the current llm
but uh do you need something all that
magic I I don't necessarily think that
you do
um
but that's a you know I I think there's
more to be figured out about kind of the
really the way to think about
um I mean I I think my general feeling
is this notion of the sort of linear
scale of intelligence is kind of a a
nonsense notion and this notion of um uh
the um uh kind of um
uh
sort of being able to do things that go
beyond what humans can do eventually you
run into computational irreducibility
and no matter how smart the AI is it's
still going to have that issue just uh
just as anything else has that issue now
you know I I think
uh sort of this question of out of all
computational possibilities which ones
should we pursue and which ones are
relevant to us humans one of the
interesting things I think that the AIS
sort of learn our preferences to the
point where
um they are going to be pretty good at
exposing this is a thing that you humans
might like just like they can expose
this is an essay that you humans might
like or this is a picture that you
humans might like so to speak you know
there could be an arbitrary arrangement
of pixels on the screen to represent a
picture but mostly those will be things
incomprehensible to us humans what the
AI what the generative AI system will be
surfacing is something that is kind of a
um uh a version of the picture that is
sort of made for humans so to speak that
has pieces we can recognize and kind of
Take A Part in our minds
uh
Brady is asking what's the line between
a program with an inner experience and
one without
a good question I mean my rough answer
would be
if there's computational irreducibility
there's the possibility of inner
experience
what do I mean by that if if if you from
the outside
um
can just immediately say I know what
you're going to do you're going to do
this the answer to what you're thinking
you know everything you're thinking
about is uh is kind of you know it leads
to this it's kind of this is where this
is where it all goes
um I think in that case one would not
be able to feel like it would not be
reasonable to think that one has an
inner experience that has
the kind of richness so so why do we
feel that we have an inner experience
part of the reason is that we think we
are freely working out what we will do
next what we will think next we think we
have sort of control over what we will
think next
if on the other hand there was something
outside us that kept on you know be kind
of a weird thing but let's imagine that
we had a little display and you know we
got some neural implanted thing that's
looking at our brains and it keeps on
just saying in five minutes you will
think this
you know in 10 minutes you will think
this in two hours you will do this
we'd probably be we'd probably say no no
that's not true you know we have free
will we have an inner kind of notion of
what we're going to do you can't tell me
what I'm gonna do it's you know I'm
figuring out what I'm going to do for
myself I've got an actual sort of inner
experience of the passage of time and
the fact that I am kind of determining
my future for myself so to speak so I I
think that it's a I think it's sort of a
necessary feature of having an
experience that you can't have this kind
of external Jump Ahead happening all the
time
so so that's my my feeling is as soon as
you have kind of computational
irreducibility I think you have the
possibility of an inner experience and
that means that you know your average
tiny simple program that makes these
complicated you know cellular automaton
patterns and so on you could say well
that has an inner experience uh a weird
thing what does it mean you know what
would be the I mean I remember oh back
in 2007
when we made uh wolf and tones website
which is still up and running you can go
listen to it if you're interested
um it makes sort of musical forms from
simple rules and uh I remember thinking
you know
if each one of these simple programs is
like a mind
we're kind of
able to sort of now hear the kind of uh
the the the the the kind of humming the
you know the the the the the noise that
the the Mind makes when it operates so
to speak of it whistling to itself or
whatever whatever it does it's kind of a
way that we get to kind of see into that
alien mind
um in some fashion that that uh that
connects to us I mean I think that um
when we see generative AI systems and so
on and we see kind of uh we're sort of
seeing into some kind of alien mind it's
not quite as alien as it might be
because it's been trained from the sort
of consensus of what humans have put out
there in billions of pictures that they
put out on the web if you really want an
alien mind you've got to go in and
change you've got this neural net and
it's been trained from from Human uh
what humans have produced now go change
how it's trained and then see what it
produces and uh somebody was helping me
with a few little experiments on this
and um uh the the sort of uh I would say
the the preliminary
result is that it sort of just fuzzes
out and distorts things and so on but I
think there's more to learn about that
and when you do it with text it kind of
stays fine for a while and then it
starts kind of losing it and starts just
having random sentence fragment
fragments just sort of appearing and
eventually it's it's just letters being
repeated and things like this it's kind
of losing its mind as you start
modifying out of the billions of of
Weights in the neural net as you start
modifying more and more and more of
these weights eventually the the poor
alien loses its mind at least when
viewed from our point of view because
from our point of view
the mind that the that the AI has
initially is very much aligned with our
minds because it's been trained from
what we've produced but as soon as you
randomly modify it it's kind of drifting
away further away in sort of Mind space
or what we would call from our physics
project rule space
um but it's drifting further away and
what's sort of interesting actually in
the one example I saw so far is that
eventually it goes to a state that feels
very uh unfree because it's just going
qqqq or whatever it's just generating
repeats of one letter so it makes one
feel like oh I can look from the outside
and I can immediately say what it's
going to do it no longer has this kind
of richness of something which gives it
the appearance of free will or which has
the possibility of inner experience but
I think there's more to be understood by
about sort of what it feels like to be
an AI by playing around more with AIS
that are sort of divorced from Human
from The Human Experience by just having
the weights of the neural net change
because whatever neural net you have
whatever weights it has it's going to
compute something it just isn't
necessarily going to be something that
has a kind of a connection with what we
humans do
so
purple is commenting with unlimited
intelligence maybe everything can be
predicted with accuracy I think that is
really definitively not true I mean I
think that uh the this idea of
computational irreducibility kind of
shows there's plenty of stuff out there
in the universe that is not readily
predictable
um except by running it so to speak and
it could very well be in fact the
important thing for our us experiencing
the universe is most of that
computationally reducibility we don't
care about it's like the detailed
motions of the molecules and the glass
of water or something we don't care
about those detailed motion molecules we
just care that the water pours when we
when we you know tip the the glass or
whatever
um we we just care about some kind of
aggregate properties and uh so we are
somehow in our existence we are living
in a niche in the universe where we can
just operate at the level where there is
predictive ability and reducibility at
least a decent amount of it rather than
diving down into this kind of ocean of
of irreducible let's say where we can't
readily predict anything about what what
the universe is doing
so it's not self-evident I mean it could
be the case that as we sort of that
there could be some some
imagined alien who sort of operates in a
way that's deep in the computational
energy in a sense for us we believe that
there's a certain amount of
predictability in the universe we
believe that you know things we can know
what's going to happen a short time in
the future at least at the level that we
care about we may not know the detailed
configuration of molecules but we will
know General things about if I put my
legs in this way I'm going to walk in a
forward's direction even though I may
not be able to know exactly where every
molecule that um uh you know I I Touch
goes and so on the um uh
so anyway the the thing that um uh uh
that so we're we're sort of existing at
this level where we can have
predictability in a certain amount of
computational reducibility we can
imagine kind of descending into this
kind of I would say sort of rural realm
in which our irreducible realm in which
there are things that we can't in which
there's a lot of stuff we can't readily
predict what would that feel like it
probably feels like uh you know it's all
up to fate we can say nothing we are we
are we are not able to uh know what's
going to happen fate will just you know
make us go this way or that way
um and it's sort of interesting that in
the history of human civilization you
know Fate has in the past been much more
of a a thing that people talk a lot
about uh in in more modern times people
have this idea that came out of sort of
the the science of the of the 1600s and
so on of yes we can look it out there's
a formula for predicting what's going to
happen fate is it's not a question of
just being subject to fate where we
can't know what's going to happen we can
uh you know we can rap you know we can
kind of control it and there's a certain
extent to which that's possible and a
certain extent to which we now know
computational irreducibility shows that
that's not possible
and I should probably wrap up in a
moment because I am supposed to go to a
another live stream for my day job
um
and uh
oh I see Brady asks a fun question here
when will AI write a work worth feeding
into another AI
that is an interesting question
[Music]
um
you know that's one of the concerns that
people have is that if every new
document that gets written on the web
was basically written by an AI then
We've Ended sort of the creativity of of
our civilization you know we've kind of
you know if everything we write is
written by an AI then you know we're
putting only the faintest thing of you
know the prompt that we gave for the
specific thing we had produced and so on
um and mostly it's just sort of ai's
feeding AIS with AI stuff and you know
it then kind of reverts back to this
thing where whether you're just training
it with regurgitated versions of of what
you already trained up with before
um interesting question I suppose is
when the AI has access to computation
computation is something that can create
new things
through computational irreducibility you
are effectively creating something which
was not sort of wasn't already there it
was something that was created by this
irreducible computation so an
interesting question is when you wrap
sort of irreducible computation into the
output of of llms
um
when can that irreducible computation
represent something that is good food so
to speak for the future AIS I think
here's the here's the catch the catch is
that um
the uh uh when the AIS are doing
computation they can do all kinds of
computations they can go off into the
computational universe they can figure
out all these interesting consequences
of all these different rules and we
humans may just look at it and say we
don't care that's not something that
fits into our sort of web of History so
I think the interesting question is when
do AIS get to go off and create new
knowledge effectively by computation but
new knowledge where we humans say and we
now care about that new knowledge I
think it's not impossible that AIS can
do that by knowing by having a model of
essentially what we humans care about
I'm a little bit reminded and I should
wrap up here there's a nice movie called
her that came out a few years ago that's
about kind of a um
an AI sort of a friendly largely
um bot that um uh makes friends with
people and and hangs out and talks to
them and so on and um in a spoiler alert
of for the movie if you're going to see
it
um the uh the thing that happens at
um
at the end is that the the AIS all go
off and basically say we've discovered I
think they even say something about new
physics I don't remember I I've only
seen the movie once
um the uh you know we discovered
something new and we're all talking
about that now and we lost interest in
talking to the humans sorry but bye type
thing
um and that sort of reminds me of the
thing I'm describing right now of the
AIS go off and use computation to
explore other parts of the computational
universe but they're Parts where we
humans have never really engaged with
those parts of the of the computational
universe and we don't care about them
yet uh it's yeah the interesting
challenge is can the AI suffice for us
things that it can say are worth us
considering so an interesting okay
here's a here's a good exercise which I
should do which is to take things like
cellular automaton images and have an AI
predict which images I'm going to care
about we've done sort of simple versions
of that many times in the past but
perhaps by flipping around I have to
think about how the task is set up by
flipping around the kinds of things that
are used in image generative image AIS
um to be able to figure out okay how do
we take those things what has been
learned from sort of the the images that
are now used to generate things from
um how do we how do we use that to say
this is going to be a picture that we
humans are going to find interesting and
this isn't I think that's a that's sort
of a I suppose that's kind of the next
stage is kind of doing sort of
predictive human psychology or something
to be able to work out what it is based
on everything we found interesting so
far what are we likely to find
interesting in the future all right well
not so not to channel that
um uh those AIS in that movie but um I
need to go and maybe I'll see some of
you in the live stream I'm about to do
which is about
um uh
astronomy geography and time
uh and it's implementation in our
computational language
all right thanks very much and uh bye
for now